Primero se cuestionan los resultados electorales,
después se deslegitima al adversario político
y después se incita a la violencia.
Esto es lo que se carga a los sistemas democráticos
y esto es lo que está haciendo Vox y el PP
lo sigue teniendo de socio.
Y el PP no puede ser ni tibio
ni neutral, ni mirar para otra parte con estas
cuestiones.
Por eso vamos a trasladar 1 denuncia a la fiscalía,
porque creemos que el código penal
es medianamente claro
en su artículo 510,
en el que regula como delitos
las conductas que fomenten públicamente el odio,
la hostilidad y la discriminación o la violencia
y que lesionen la dignidad de las personas.
Queremos que caiga sobre Abascal y sobre Vox
todo el peso de la ley
y del código penal.
Por eso es 1 denuncia por las declaraciones
de Santiago Abascal,
pero también es 1 denuncia
por los ataques a las sedes socialistas.
Constituyen, bajo nuestro punto de Vista,
1 ejemplo Cara claro
de delito de odio contra el partido socialista